[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello hello be a nice fellow play
[Music]
upgrade to shaver routine with bevel in
2-inch shaving system designed for a
smooth bump free shave dermatologist
approved proven to reduce and prevent
razor bumps discoloration and irritation
there's a reason 9 out of 10 Belleville
customers come back month after month
you deserve to look good get your bevel
trimmers shave system today at get bevel
calm for a limited time with every
trimmer purchase get the first month of
bevel shave system free hits a get bevel
calm / handle
that's get bevel calm sighs Hannibal for
your first month free co-host Tony trim
hey special guest Kevin Smith hey
everybody thanks man thanks for having
we should tell that maybe it's a boring
story but we tried to do this in Chicago
yeah and I guess it was United before
the incident Oh
delayed me and and so we didn't wind up
doing the thing and as if you know that
wasn't a reason enough to hate them then
then all of a sudden they start dragging
people through aisles and [ __ ] that was
uh that's pretty but it was the it was
the the security that did it though the
United I think United was here's my one
angle and potential theory I wonder if
United said hey can you guys talk to
this guy and get him to leave and they
probably thought all that guy goes see
two big guys and he's got he's gonna
leave they're gonna talk to him and then
those guys got there and they and United
was thinking what why are you doing that
well if this seems like like by the time
the police get involved they're not even
really told like oh the situation is we
just need to clear up four seats and you
know the computer randomly picks like
it's already escalated at the point
where like this guy won't get off the
plane and I'm sure they're just like
alright well it's our job to get them
get him off the plane right and I too
believe me not that extremely but that
was very extreme and I can't even
imagine acting like that
as you know authority figure in this day
and age and 2017 so you be just afraid
of being sued data but yeah just
dragging somebody and you know
everybody's like bleeding out of the
face and like it just that's the insane
thing yeah it's just like every aspect
of it there was no part of it that that
made you go like yeah I guess I guess
that's what I would have done super
aggressive and the type of person that
would drag somebody once I got him if he
was like 21 once I got to about Road 19
something's not right about this I'm not
just on the moral level but like does
not want to go and I saw the video he
didn't want to go yeah I speak as I
couldn't you know what I could speak to
this subject knowledgeably yeah as a
fellow who was asked to get off a plane
once was not dragged no blood involved
but like I got kicked off a Southwest
flight for being heavy and [ __ ] like
that and I remember being at the time
mortified right then I saw this video
and I was like oh my god I got off so
light so that would have been my
nightmare dude if somebody dragged me up
an aisle and my shirt went up I mean
[ __ ] the dragon at the aisle all they my
nightmare would be they come in they go
stand up they just lift up my shirt so
when I saw his video of this poor guy
getting dragged not only is he bloody
but he's his shirts going up as well I'm
like this is hell on earth he should own
the airline after that and they just
announced recently that everything like
you know we settled amicably oh it's
already handled it I've read that
yesterday so what do you think that
means because that video look like you
could have owned United after that yeah
I think think about ten million yeah ten
million plural millions yeah it's gotta
be multiples right it's multiple maybe
I wonder because they gotta end that as
quickly as possible
like you know already within 24 hours of
the incident
yeah the world that turned on United and
granted they said that even with people
going I'm boycott and they only dropped
like a few percentage in market share
but instantly they want to make good and
fix it as quickly as possible but you
think a nice up to that because you
remember right after that happened they
started releasing stuff about the guy
that wasn't true yeah there was a story
where the like I think this guy might
have touched somebody yeah well he was
doing like prostitution for drugs or
some [ __ ] like that but then they proved
that that it was a different doctor with
the same last name so they were just
they mixed it all up do you think United
was up to that PR stunt do you think
United PR was I way I wouldn't put it
past them in as much as like in my
situation when I dealt with the
Southwest like they threw me off a plane
and but not like in midair so yeah I
should be thankful but they told me get
off and where we San Francisco and the
Bay Area yeah and then I started
tweeting about it and after an hour of
like tweets where I was trying to be
funny and [ __ ] but clearly I was like
pissed and hurt or we were [ __ ] like
somebody come running through the
airport cone and and I saw him booked
past me and I was leaning on a wall
outside a restaurant and all sudden I
see this person like double back and see
me and I go mr. Smith please stop
tweeting like what happened what
happened just like it's just we're gonna
try to fix this as quickly as possible
and she'll like that and so I remember I
said there's nothing to fix here like
this is [ __ ] outrageous like yeah
they threw me out he said I was too fat
I could put the armrest down like I
don't get this [ __ ] so in an aisle and I
was in the middle seat you in the middle
seat damn I didn't know that he could do
that yeah you're too big they got a
policy got a south/southwest has a
policy about heavyset people in a super
fine print [ __ ] yeah and and they act
they can like they don't ask you when
you check-in like alpha me you know when
you buy a ticket online nobody sitting
there going how much do you how much you
weigh yeah they would never ask you a
question that would make you go well
[ __ ] I'm not buying this ticket yeah so
once you got the ticket once you bought
the ticket then at the gate they can
sighs you up and be like you might need
to buy an extra ticket [ __ ] like that
damn oh it was weird and that was my
kill II seal that was my like kryptonite
like I labored under the false delusion
my whole life that nobody knew I was fat
but me and I was you know and it I think
having a career helped like I you know I
was fat when I was a kid and people have
zero compunction about being a fat piece
of [ __ ] but then when my when clerks
happen yeah suddenly you stop being fat
and once again big guy we love the big
guy right but God what you want to do so
you know for years I was like oh I'm not
fat anymore I'm just the big guy
yeah and then that Southwest thing was
like oh [ __ ] I'm fat and and it was
public like top of the Google news page
for God how long three days straight why
was Kevin Smith still thrown off the
plane still fetch when that was
terrifying but Southwest sorry Southwest
sent someone in to talk to me yeah and
they were one of the most people I've
ever spoken to on the phone of course
they're insanely like this woman gets me
man but she understands I seriously got
[ __ ] and these people owe me and stuff
is right on they're finally doing the
right thing and then they put out a
statement that didn't match the
conversation that we had aloud so I
would imagine so to answer a long story
to answer that question yeah would I put
it past a corporation and be like well
this guy's no angel everybody I hear a
large hooker yeah yeah we don't like
ogres I wouldn't put it past a
corporation get the PR to dig up some
dirt so they don't look so bad and that
might have been part of the reason for
the quick settlement as well I mean look
if I was in charge United I would have
settled I would immediately been on on
public airwaves going like he can sue us
but we're just gonna offer him a hundred
million dollars right now cuz oh my god
we were as wrong as it [ __ ] gets
there's you know the Nazis and then like
200 layers down there's us and we're
still on the list and what we did was
bad so we need to make good but for the
first few days they were like well you
know yes it was a little much but we
have a policy they tried to pass the way
they'd always passed historically and
then video is just so egregious yeah
nobody's gonna let that fly like this is
a human
dignity dude and for the for a [ __ ]
ticket that like you weren't even
offering more than 500 bucks there was
no incentive yeah anyone to get off the
plane and so then they randomly picked
four people and then clearly this guy
wanted to get where he was going
yeah and if I'm the person at the desk
and like where I'm sorry we've randomly
picked you and they're like well no I'm
not going I'd be like well it's this
ain't worth the hassle I'm gonna pick
somebody else yeah and and maybe raise
the money and now every airline has been
authorized to raise it up to what 10k a
pop if they're gonna ask you to like not
take a flight used to be they'd offer
you like a round-trip ticket yeah coach
and [ __ ] and then like if they really
need it they start jacking it up but now
we all know they're authorized to go to
10k which instantly means the moment
somebody the airline from now it's at
the end of time is like we're looking
for people who are willing to jump off
the plane or you know go a later flight
instantly you go up that desk and be
like I will take $10,000 right yeah a
voucher for 10 cuz I know you're allowed
to go that high so let's just start
there and down yeah also people have
your employees lap up for a little bit
do you know what I mean we should be
just some terminology from the airline
industry I'm not familiar with hold
tight it's mostly safe here I'll do you
one better like these are the people
they need to get on the plane where it
was a crew for flight leaving out of st.
Louis or something like it yeah it's so
they're all expert fliers
how about standard like you know how to
maintain your balance of gravity cuz
you're on a plane 96 times a day yeah
whenever they put on the put on your
seatbelt light and [ __ ] most of those
cats still trucking around so in that
world it's like I get it you got to get
somewhere but or hang out in the
bathroom
love that that was an option by that
[ __ ] tickets they can charge me
double the kid in the room close the
door and just sit there alone sitting on
a toilet
people knock him like I'm sorry I bought
the special ticket you just here [ __ ]
yeah just leaned on a wall just hold
tight guys travel a lot you trouble its
trouble so and this is when you travel
now I imagine you're placing your
careers where you travel up front yeah
when you sit up front and you see
somebody come from the back chamber to
use the bathroom do you get tight I
don't get tight but I say that man is
brave I respect him I travel with the
guy who plays Jay to my salad Bob a lot
Jason used yeah and he considers himself
an expert traveler and he gets real
shitty with the rest of the world that
doesn't do it like his way right so I've
seen him fight with people he tells a
story about [ __ ] some dude was like
he got onto the plane he wanted to put
his bag into the seat but some [ __ ]
dude was like no I'm gonna I'm gonna
leave it there he's like yeah but
there's room and they over had been he's
like now well this is where I want to
put it and Jason got real tight and
finally it was just like your piece of
[ __ ] like hola it's the guy I see the
guy was already there he was in his own
seat yeah but he and he had his bag
under and Jay was sitting next to him
yeah and his bag was where Jays feet
would be I like that little yeah the
taint first-class you're not sure where
the bag is supposed to go and it was one
of those arbitrary things
and the guy was just like no I was here
before you [ __ ] this and Jay just got
voluble with them like you know that
[ __ ] that will make everyone in a plane
turn around like not as much as like you
know this planes but their bomb on a
plane but if you yell loud before the
plane takes off you're a piece of [ __ ]
everyone in that tube is like we're
gonna see something real yeah like
everyone's gonna stop being civil yeah
this guy's gonna fight and we're all
stuck together
it's a watch develop forever what
happens a lot
I travel as I go out to heavy the night
before and I'll have a first-class
ticket and I'll miss that flight and
then the next flight I only have a coach
ticket and then when I walk through in
my mind I want to explain to everybody
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
so the way we linked up was that we were
looking for guests and we usually have
just booked other comedians or musician
friends that we work with before but
Tony was looking through the Chicago
Reader and saw that you were playing the
brick he was like let's get Kevin Smith
on a podcast great idea this tune is
called a longshot let's try it I found
out we gonna rap by the same people and
you you plan to Vic in Chicago how was
that joke wonderful right yeah it was
Jay and Silent Bob get old this show I
do with Jack any it crush they were warm
crowd they liked us there yeah it was a
nice place I think
Chicago is probably the place in the
world one place in the world where I get
honestly recognized the most but but
interrupted with the least so people go
hey and they just moved the [ __ ] on yeah
like and they think because I'm because
I'm a Zac Teague man yeah and I wear
layers and [ __ ] like that that I'm local
right like oh he looks like it yes he
looks like deep-dish and stuff like that
so it's a wonderful play and I have a
very fond memory of our band married we
just celebrated 18 years of marriage and
like one of the greatest days we ever
had in our marriage we were doing like a
press tour for Jersey girl and so we
wound up in Chicago for a three-day
weekend and it was February and
generally [ __ ] the weather there is
not that great but it was one of these
weird kind of like it's [ __ ] you know
greenhouse effect and so it's 70 degrees
in in February which could also happen
yeah it's and it was beautiful we want
up and down Michigan Avenue
and that was like that was the day where
I was a host yet like everybody see here
seems to know me more than other places
in life who writes like it was really
wonderful and then we had [ __ ] great
sex that night and [ __ ] so Chicago
became our place yeah stuck in the brain
yes a warm place
how many Pike has nine yeah I do let me
see the active ones are SModcast which I
try to do every week normally I do it
the Scott Mosier the guy I've been doing
it with we've been 10 years we're
celebrating 10 years of podcasting the
shoes Wow so but he's off in France so
I've been like other people will come on
and and lately we've been trying to
escape which work down nice chainsaw Bob
get all this J's podcast that I do with
them it's about him staying off heroin
and oxycontin so it's kind of
intervention podcast very funny where he
just talks about it's like going to an
AAA meeting but if everyone was drunk
except you because it's a bar or
whatever the [ __ ] and you know he tells
great [ __ ] stories even the user
stories are wonderful and the [ __ ]
sex stories are great so it's just like
spending that's interesting it's kind of
fun show that's the other one I do
Hollywood babble-on that'll do tonight
at the improv here on Melrose every
every Friday night me and this guy Ralph
Garman news on the radio out here on K
rock do a like a I guess it's kinda how
would you describe it it's kind of like
cabaret show but we just sit around talk
about entertainment news make fun of
it's really easy shooting fish in a
barrel but we've been doing that one we
sold that at The Improv on Melrose since
we got there so about four years
trailers so that's done every Friday
every Friday and if it's on Friday we
jump on to Saturday but the ten o'clock
show so it's nice because he's locally
strong like I'm outside of California
people like hey made clerk's ones but
like here in Los Angeles raps on the
radio every day yeah so he can be like
come see me and Kevin at The Improv and
boom we sell out every week if I had to
do it myself you how would have stopped
a long time ago cuz I couldn't put 200
asses in Los Angeles yeah this is a
tough [ __ ] town well yeah you burn
your drawers very very fast exactly but
the good news is he's on radio and
apparently like they gave me some metric
the other day I was
the over the audience turnover on radio
is eight minutes oh so eight minutes you
got one audience eight minutes later a
completely different [ __ ] audit yeah
so that's that's hitting a lot of
[ __ ] people that makes sense cuz it's
been time when I've been on a radio show
for an hour and a half I've been on
different radios with one vibe and time
every few minutes and we're here with
Hannibal Buress
I got a review when Hannibal Burres he's
playing the guys we're here with Hannah
bubbly are you guys having a stroke
right here radio reset man the like it's
10:20 we're real animals like so you're
podcasting a lot this is getting in the
way of your filmmaking time like how do
you I'd walk quit film out make him for
like three years when I was doing that I
did this movie called red state yeah
that's crazy turned that's a weird movie
I love movies but it was a moment time
where I was like you know what I'm done
with this I was having what I guess like
what you would call midlife professional
midlife crisis where I was just like the
job doesn't make sense how it's done
when you makin movies making them is one
thing you know whatever they cost
selling them is a completely different
cost we had this movie called Clark's -
it costs five million to make and we'd
[ __ ] tighten the belt and [ __ ]
like you know I didn't take a salary
everyone took low figures and then when
they marketed the movie they spent 10
million to sell it and I'm like Jesus we
could have [ __ ] use that money at
least pay people for their [ __ ] time
yeah and instead they'll take that money
and spend it just to try to get people
to come see them yeah yeah and my shits
rarefied taste anyway so it's like why
would you spend all that like people
give a [ __ ] about a movie with a - in a
title yeah they're gonna go anyway right
you're never gonna convert anybody new
so I had this kind of like breakdown
where when we did that movie red state I
was like I'm not gonna do it again like
that it's ridiculous I'm gonna take it
out and and and take it around myself
and stuff and so after that flick I kind
of stepped out of the movie business and
all I did was podcast we had a
do a TV show on AMC in the 6th season
that came out of a podcast called comic
book men so I just started doing a bunch
of filming then three years later I was
doing a podcast an episode of SModcast
we started telling this dopey story
about some [ __ ] we read online about a
guy was giving away a mansion a house in
a room in his mansion and in Brighton
England you could live you have the run
of the [ __ ] house do whatever you
want
but for two hours every day you had to
agree to dress up like a walrus and he
would throw you fish and crabs and you
couldn't talk so we were like this is
like oh my god it turned out to be a
hoax but boy capture our imagination and
it spun into this movie idea where I was
I hadn't made a movie in three years but
I was like [ __ ] I want to see that movie
we talked about this thing which became
to us yeah and I kept saying like where
the [ __ ] brake you can hear me it's a
wonderful episode of the podcast
SModcast 2:59 because very rarely is
there a microphone on a good idea right
I usually have it when you're in the
shower jerking off or drive and smoking
weed or whatever you like oh [ __ ] and
then you start develop again but you
literally hear us we were sitting around
doing this [ __ ] yeah yeah and you start
going like Oh imagine if it was this and
you could do this and we've done it a
thousand times like make pretend and
[ __ ] yeah but this was something where I
was like well I would I would [ __ ]
want to see that movie like how come
nobody will make that movie and I said
like we're all the brave filmmakers
we'll make this man the walrus and I
remembered I used to be a brave
filmmaker so I was like maybe I should
[ __ ] try it I know how to do this
like I was at a hard transition to go
from comedy to now because the first
movies I made were all about funny the
comedy the transition to stand around
talking and I don't consider myself a
comic I don't think anybody else does
but I back doored onto stage by by the
movies because when you make a movie go
to a film festival after the movie got
to go out and [ __ ] stand up for it
sorry and speak for it and [ __ ] so you
know I I I couldn't get up and be
informative like I'd been to so many Q&A
so though the filmmakers and everybody
treats it so earnestly and like you know
well you know as we were pulling this
shot off
light was going and who knew if we were
gonna get it you know [ __ ] like that
really come on you may pretend there was
a camera so I didn't want to like I tell
those stories so I'd be like let me tell
you the story about how we got the cat
to [ __ ] on cue
in the movies that's [ __ ] up so you
just start telling anecdotes and [ __ ]
and one
my fee and I love stand-up comedy I love
like Carlin I work got to work with him
Sam Kinison when I was a kid I was big
comedy nut and then I fell in love with
Spalding Gray who was a monologuist who
like I was like oh [ __ ] that's like
being a comic with no expectations you
know when you're a comic people like you
better make me laugh spoken where yes if
you're like well I'm a monologues people
like well oh [ __ ]
so if we laugh it's a treat yeah yeah so
I'm not crazy approach no pressure
whatsoever man lower the bar so I
started like I backdoor it into it I'm
after all the film festivals I just
wound up talking and then ologies would
be like do you want to come speak after
your movie and be like [ __ ] yeah because
anytime somebody's watching the movie
even if it's dead movie like Mallrats
came out and died and so there was a
college in Delaware going oh we're gonna
show your movie do you want to come Q
and I was like [ __ ] yeah man somebody's
gonna watch that [ __ ] I drove to
Delaware and started like doing that and
any place that was having a screening
that go to and I was at Rutgers once in
Camden his buckaroos University and
there's like a couple campuses in Jersey
it was the Camden Cameron campus right
outside of like Philadelphia and so I
like you know I get a place and I would
QA for an hour of two hours and then I'd
stop and show something like oh here's a
cartoon we made yeah so I go out and
smoke cigarettes cause a cigarette
smoker in those days and so and then I
go out and QA for another two hours
sounds like a four hour night and so
sitting there chit-chatting at the break
with the kids that run the student union
yeah the sack kids and they're like boy
you talk long Wow we're here what the
[ __ ] I decide Rove all the way here and
it was like literally at an hour and
half drop yeah I was like I drove all
the way here like well you talk way more
than Jeannie Garofalo she's here last
week no Janeane Garofalo here right on
I've worked with her and Dogma
I said I was great like yeah she did an
hour and left right after that she was
done how's it go I guess you know what
maybe that's how she does it she goes
yeah but we paid her $20,000
I wish there had been a camera on me
it captured my face the moment I was
like somebody would pay for this yeah
that's the what we do we have a Student
Activity and fund and everyone who puts
in for their tuition they pay for the
[ __ ] so will they ask when we ask the
kids who they want and they all want you
but a lot of colleges like you I'll be
honest because you're free because you
don't charge and I was like I mean I'm
supposed to charge down for free cuz I'm
like that's how I started it was free
screenings and [ __ ] so then I was like
wow I should get gas money and so I
started asking for guess it was all
backdoor dude because I could never see
myself as much as I loved I revere
comedians I never thought of myself as a
comedian because median jumps up on a
stage without a net and generates and
they don't rely on the audience except
to laugh yeah me I would get up there
and be like somebody asked me a question
or else I got nothing to [ __ ] talk
about give me a direction to go in and
so they'd ask a question and I oh I can
answer that so is Q&A I look a little
bit of cue metric fuckton a bag yeah so
suddenly like you know being someplace
like where you have enough experience
standing up in front of people and
telling stories you know you can start
putting that together and just start
doing shows like I used to follow the
movies and then I just stopped playing
the movies because I'd be of colleges
and I'd be like y'all saw this movie
right there's just QA that'll give us
more time to talk yeah so longest one I
did was in Red Bank in New Jersey seven
hours it was like the Springsteen Q&A
we're like by the end of the show no
break that's a lot of repeat people
questions no there's no repeat people no
we got down to we got down to the bottom
of the barrel which is like you know
[ __ ] boxers or briefs yeah but not me
not repeat questions but different
people we had an audience it was 1,500
year oh wow you wouldn't even after
Spacey got busy play there yeah you know
that's my time wait no I have
but you know it yeah I think I heard
yeah okay so no so what point of that
seven hours were you like I can't do
this anymore I didn't matter it was I at
a certain point you're like let's see
how long we can go then it becomes an
endurance trial we're like let's see who
breaks first me to the audience yeah and
so like halfway through half the
audience goes because about two hours in
people are like is it gonna end
like when does he wrap up when is the
good night and so about the three hour
mark people start going alright I guess
I'm gonna go what's up it started at
seven seven and then after we were done
I went to my comic book store we did
like signing because there were a bunch
of people like we want to buy [ __ ] and I
was like I can't turn him away it was a
long night Wow but by the seven hour
mark all that's left is you
and it may be quarter of the audience
yeah but it's it's crazy like this you
know what I'm saying it it I was like oh
my god we went through this together
and finally the place is like you have
to stop it have to go the place is like
we let you go as long as we could like
some people have to go home dude Union
Building
so I backdoor it into it and it's always
been another spinning plate I like to
spin a lot of plates and the movie thing
was probably you know that was the thing
I was first known for but standing up
and talking and trying to be funny I got
lucky Sony put it on a DVD called an
evening with Kevin Smith it was meant to
be a series of DVDs starring a bunch of
filmmakers yeah there's this wonderful
guy
Michael Stratford who worked at Sony and
he did he was a guy that created bonus
value like when the laser disc and DVD
business first took off he was like what
if we interviewed directors and showed
all the behind the scenes [ __ ] like that
so he's visionary so I'd worked at the
Mount of Dogma DVD and he went to see me
talk at the Academy one day I did like
Q&A at the Academy and he was like have
you ever shot those and as why why would
you shoot that and he's gone funny and I
was like nah not at all I said but I
loved it because then I could probably
stop telling some of those stories like
anywhere I went life people be like tell
that Superman stories I wrote Superman
at one point so that was like an hour
right there so I was like if I do the
[ __ ] DVD then I could be like oh here
you just watch it and I never have
tell that story again and I thought the
college gigs would shrink up because I
was busy trying to have a film career
but at the same time any place that was
like come talk to us I was like [ __ ]
yeah so I was like if I do this DVD
it'll kill the my college gigs but
that's okay because they'll have
something to watch but it didn't do that
it increased the college to the gigs the
DVD became a commercial where people
like oh we want to send live now so I
started doing more and more so I was
always able to spend that plate while
doing a movie [ __ ] as well oh so now
you're completely done with the movies
no I went back you went back I made this
movie called Tosk yeah then I made a
movie called yoga hosers nobody likes
them but maybe I'll give a [ __ ] yeah and
now we're making so I came back and now
you're this summer end of the summer is
a sequel to Jay and Silent Bob strike
back called Jay and Silent Bob reboot
that's what we're gonna do okay and what
is that when you guys gonna start
shooting we start shooting that end of
August beginning of September so that's
something that I'll write direct and be
in as well nice nice those are good
movies yeah clerks I mean I love clerks
I mean I love all the movies they're
mine right but like I can see where
people well that don't like back in the
days and when I was in high school that
was just like the the go to that was
like you know like I had friends from
different walks of life
it was either clerks or Friday which
crew I was [ __ ] with that day I was
the director was F Carrie gray right
yeah for Friday's well Friday was
IceCube but he's in it and he wrote it
but he didn't directed oh I thought
pretty sure because somebody Google it
I'm pretty sure as f Carrie gray yeah
like the F gary Gray we all know the guy
who just literally directed fast and
furious furious is or fate of the
Furious 8 of the Furious number 8 of the
Furious but I'm pretty sure if I
remember my film history correctly I
always thought it was you're right
you're right yeah
so who directed F gary Gray yeah so I
met F Terry gray learned something new
today I know that's what I'm here to
educate a matter paragraph right before
he
did did he do straight out of Compton as
well yes yeah right a straight right
before the movie came out he's mixing it
I was mixing yoga and I was coming out
of a building he was coming out with
building he was Kevin Smith yeah he goes
F Carragher hey man how are you
and he goes let's take a picture man
because you did clerks and I did black
clerks which was Friday that's how they
said that yeah I felt kind of flattered
by that I was like really I gotta ask
cube for a piece yeah a taste of
Friday's make me a rich man yeah clerks
was white people's Friday where I'm from
we like to think of we have a bunch of
rappers and musicians on here that's
what's uh what's been your toughest song
clearing for a film I can tell you my
most expensive I don't know if it's my
toughest but the most expensive was we
made that movie tusk and we made it for
like three million dollars and then even
building the walrus suit that Justin
Long War was not as expensive as this
paying for the Fleetwood Mac song yes
that was if I remember correctly
$250,000 oh you couldn't get you just
couldn't you just like get a cover of it
you had it would have been a hundred and
twenty-five thousand because you still
have to pay for the publish yeah and the
performance or two different-sized he
said [ __ ] it let's just go all if we
were we were there you know you're
already halfway there why not get the
original that inspired the movie I wrote
that movie listening to that song on
yeah okay Pete and it's also like
there's two songs if you're gonna go see
a movie called tusk about a walrus yes
two songs you expect to hear one of or
maybe both if you if it was a rich man's
film I am The Walrus
yeah poor tusk and I felt like tusk is
the title track let's go for that he'd
never get a Beatles song as a way to
expense yeah did 250,000 bucks man that
was way more than what the buzz racing
game he cost me to make was he had
50,000 budget of tusk three million
three million so about think about this
clerks first movie I made twenty seven
thousand five hundred and seventy-five
bucks Wow so [ __ ] putting that song
in toss cost ten times as much this is
just making clerks
is that what they just flat quoted or
did you have to talk them down to that I
think they were like they hope go away
at this number
oh so we were but the people financed in
the movie were just like dude I get it
you need the track and everything else
like you saved money in other places
that this will be the one extravagance
but why not and so I you know I think if
I remember correctly I'm not gonna say
like they weren't happy about it or
something like that but there were very
stringent set of rules yeah like we
couldn't sometimes complain once yes and
the trailer couldn't work it into the
score because there's like some
sometimes you have a great song you work
it into the side worked a little bita
something a little bit like like when
Prince did the Batman soundtrack there
was a song scandalous that sounds like
the score I don't know which one one
first if he wrote scandalous and then
Danny Elfman adapted it for his core or
this Danny Elfman score happened and
then Prince wrote scandalous using a
piece of the score but any time you use
a piece of the score in a song or vice
versa it's cool thing they were like you
can't wow and we had at one point our
first rake who did our score wasn't
reminiscent like wasn't like oh that's
[ __ ] hands down to us but in this
travel montage he used the drum the
jumpy that sounded insanely similar dude
yeah and Lindsey Buckingham was like you
can't do that we had to change the jumpy
million that's rude what a million yeah
they should let you do whatever the [ __ ]
you want with that song I haven't seen
tusk but I'm seeing it now that I know
that the song never mind putting a
[ __ ] trailer together just a video of
me going do you know how much it cost
you get a Fleetwood Mac song and an
independent movie about a guy who tells
no guy into a walrus quarter of a
million go see tusk was a regular I mean
a four major artist what's the usual
clearance for you about thirty to fifty
thousand something like that but
generally more if it's if you're talking
major artists they set the price 50 on
each side which is minimum
grin right there like if you wanted to
what's a hot track right now I'm sorry
my head stuck in the bad boogy boogy by
Miko's now I would I would imagine in
this day and age it's different because
they're like oh we could put it into
commercials we can pin it into this we
could put it into this but I can't
imagine they get away with that in the
movie for less than $75,000 right yeah
which is weird because you'd imagine
it's like your band you had a song and
some movies like I want to use your song
in movie I'd be like oh my god it's a
free commercial for that [ __ ] song
right yeah but there's a whole business
dedicated like no we want to make some
money off that - yeah where's been times
with friends of mine said yeah you can
use a song and then I go to the
publishing house they could shut you to
30,000 or one time we went for my second
comedy special live from Chicago we did
this song gibberish rap but it was over
producers beat clams Casino and so we
went through the process of trying to
clear that but then they said you know
is some German producer who was obscure
party and he couldn't even find the guy
like seriously they were looking for
this guy to clear this dumb sample right
and they couldn't even find the guy his
representation nothing he was just like
and nobody wants to take the really
wanna come out like you know [ __ ] a
minute later and the deals done and be
like that's my German track you owe me a
billion dollars but then I read I redid
the song for him and I made it sound
almost exactly alike but I redid it with
synthesizers and whatnot and added an
extra beat or have to hear or something
like that really kind of Center was like
nope they don't want to take the risk a
little too close yeah for an obscure but
this is like something that you'd
probably wouldn't even find like in the
bargain bin at a vinyl record store
anywhere in the world like I don't I
don't even know where clams [ __ ]
somebody somewhere in the history of
well I mean you don't even have to go
that far back remember it was a hangover
or hangover to Mike Tyson had it yeah
tattoo Oh
and then the artist who made it the
tattoo who created the tattoos that
that's my artwork and nobody got a
clearance for it oh [ __ ] so they were
either gonna have to pay the tattoo
artist or go in and digitally change the
tattoo I forget which they did but
either way was a pricey proposition so
you could see why these cats are like
huh not unless I got a signed piece of
paper that says that the German dude
[ __ ] is okay with this you might have
to go another way it's interesting like
that man I let me ask you a question
real quick was that you oh you were went
to school in Chicago yeah where'd you go
Steinmetz Steinman's yeah did you ever
see that that was it called cheaters
yeah what they mentioned Steinmetz Lots
time it's nightmares was the not the
cheating snow Steinmetz was the cheat in
the school they were the one that
cheated and Whitney Young they were the
good kids
kids have you ever seen that movie I saw
it a while back on HBO's real movie
here's something about this wait were
you at Steinmetz when that was going on
no I was at Whitney Young in Whitney
Young has a 7 and 8th grade gifted
program that you have to test into right
so I tested in this sixth grade what's
Whitney Young for seven and eighth grade
and I was a [ __ ] and so it went so it
came out the movie came out in eighth
grade I think the cheaters movie and we
will make fun of Steinmetz and then they
put me out of Whitney Young I just did
an automatic transfer to my neighborhood
school which was Diamond all right so
you weren't there when the cheating
happened
I think we're any of the kids there I
was at Whitney Young when the cheating
happened where they're kids like rock
stars or is just a nebulous it was they
were mathletes right yeah it was uh yeah
I think mathletes wait I don't I'm a
dark here what there's a story movie HBO
did called cheaters and apparently it's
time that's back in the day there was a
teacher played by Jeff Daniels yeah in
the movie but the teacher was like he
found a way for folks to go into this
math competition and maybe what was it
it was based on
not card counting but there was there
was something to the competition that
kind of gave them an edge 20 years 94 93
94 95 is but yes so Whitney Young is one
of the top high schools in Chicago so
they were always winning this type of
thing and Steinmetz that time is kind of
a middling kind of a bad school and
nobody would expect Steinmetz to win
this type of academic competition
especially against Whitney Young
powerhouses and so Steinmetz won and
people couldn't believe it but any found
they get found out that they were
cheating yeah and then I was at both
schools like wait and that's because
Jeff Daniels had the secret algorithm or
something yes it was a move they made of
actually just flat-out stole the test no
but yeah I don't I wish I knew
remember more about it but I just do
remember feeling real because Whitney
young people used to make fun of
Steinmetz a lot you just brought that up
[Laughter]
[Music]
you see people talking about the
award-winning bevel trimmer now you can
hold one you say bevel trimmer now you
can hold one yourself yo into inch
saving system designed for a smooth bump
free shave dermatologist approved proven
to reduce and prevent razor bumps
discoloration and irritation
there's a reason 9 out of 10 bevel
customers come back month of the month
you deserve to look good no waiting this
o order shipping now bevel trimmer
features four hours of cordless power
just in case you want to walk around on
the streets in shape you good
zero gap adjustment in seconds for a
limited time with every trimmers just
get the free month of bevel shave system
free hits a get bed vogue.com slash
Hannibal that's get bevel dot-com slash
Hannibal for your first month free with
trimmer purchase I watched a little bit
of the comic book man what I really
enjoyed was a how low stakes the
negotiations just a show about my friend
yeah that like I you know I would have
had to be in Jersey and hanging out with
them to see what they actually put on
the show yeah well yeah it's very
nothing life's not on the line i watch
$30 but it's kind of booked this morning
I want 25 alright I want a hundred for
this all the best I could do is 80 yeah
but I need to get a hundred now 80 is
the best I could do
all right 80 yes while somebody's like
I'll take my [ __ ] and go I'm not a
shitty way but look no I'd rather
that was the parameters of the show it
was pitched as Pawn Stars in a comic
book store yeah somebody from there's a
guy who used to run this company called
the original media Charlie Corwin and he
was friends with this woman Elise Sidon
who had produced red-stained she was
like I know a guy I went to school with
and he went to speak to the AMC people
and they had great success with the this
show called The Walking Dead oh yeah I
watched it season 1 and they're like
they're afraid that the audience when
they go shoot season two is gonna forget
about the show and when they come back
the audience ain't gonna be there again
so they want to make more geek
programming that was our show came early
because there was a moment in time where
someone [ __ ] was just like what if
nobody watches The Walking that sounds
like a exact keep it might have been but
they so that's how we got in they were
just like we want to make another geek
program and I said I don't have any
ideas I said but if you said cheap way
to do it I say you should do Pawn Stars
in a comic book store
and he's like I'm gonna take that back
to AMC so they took a DMC and and AMC
liked it and and they were like we'll
give you $10,000 to shoot a sizzle reel
pilot I was like how do you shoot a
reality show pilot because the idea was
you go find a comic book store in
America so I told the dude I was like
we'll go find the most acerbic comic
book store staff in America and shoot
the show there and so Ames seems like we
like the idea there's 10,000 shoot a
sizzle reel as how do we do that without
knowing what comic book store it's gonna
be at because we have to do a nationwide
search he goes well the sizzle reel is
just a fictional version of what the
show would be so we just gotta shoot
something we go to any comic book store
and I said well we can shoot it at my
comic book store and that was the first
time in [ __ ] four months that I'd
mentioned that I had a comic book store
yeah while we were building a comic book
show and he's like you have a comic book
story
yeah Red Bank New Jersey Jane saw Bob
she's like why don't you [ __ ] say
that he's like you're talking about
going to find like a nationwide search
why didn't you say I said why it felt
braggy I guess yeah so I said well maybe
you know use like what people don't want
it throw a party at their house I mean I
just knew my friends then I knew they
wouldn't be into it so as business
increased like crazy after the shows not
as much as if we were like a Cake Boss
or something like that like because
everyone loves [ __ ] cake not everyone
loves comics yeah can't eat a count but
you could [ __ ] eat a cake so okay you
know the cake boss lines you go around a
cake boss story look [ __ ] man the TV
show does right by our store was ready
to close about you know I was maybe when
when the comic book men happened we're
about a year away from me shuttering it
down we've been open for like eleven
years at that point I was like a lot of
other comic book stores were closed and
they'd gone digital brick-and-mortar was
going away so I was like you know what
we've done we've done more than I
imagined we would yeah probably got
another year then this thing happened
with AMC and so they liked the idea and
I told Charlie that I had a store and he
goes I said well there's dudes that work
at the store they could stand in for
whoever the real guys are gonna be
because they do a podcast they do a
podcast called tell him Steve David
they've been doing that for almost 10
years I was like they're pretty funny
the dudes like let me listen to them you
listen to the show and he goes that's
the [ __ ] show you idiot he's going on
stars a comic store he's going these two
dudes your friends they sound like
they've been married thirty [ __ ]
years the bicker there's great yeah so
he bought I am seated they wanted to
come meet him but I said I got to talk
to these dudes first he said what do you
mean I said my friends aren't like most
people they don't give a [ __ ] about TV
they don't wanna yeah this ain't gonna
be exciting to them in haste yeah he
goes who don't like being on TV I was
like Walter Flanagan so I called in my
friend Walter who runs the store then
I'd got in the store for him to run we
used to buy comic books and [ __ ] and
when we were younger he was like my
dream to run a comic store as a yeah I'd
love to own a comic store because I want
to own it that's too much responsibility
because I just want to run it get 50%
off the books so after clerks happened I
was able to buy a comic store and be
like here run it you'll get 50
an off-the-books I let him run it like
it was his and [ __ ] so I called him up
and I was like hey man you know I am see
he's like walking dead I was yeah
walking dead they're interested in doing
a count a reality show set at the comic
book and then click he just [ __ ] like
why'd you do that dude why'd you hang up
because I don't want to do that [ __ ] I
won't be a no reality show I said why
not he goes cuz I don't want to be
Snooki response I said why not miss look
he made a lot of money this year and
[ __ ] he because I had my dignity is more
important than [ __ ] money and [ __ ]
and I was like umm I get it I said but
look you know we were talking about
shutting this store down next year if we
do the show and the show takes off
that's like a free commercial [ __ ]
store you know maybe that's the reason
doing it goes you know what that is
don't fine couldn't argue with that he
couldn't argue with thank good not he
said the only thing he goes you got to
get Bryan that's my friend Bryan his
friend Bryan Johnson
he goes you gotta get Brian to do it too
and I said but Bryan doesn't work at the
store and he goes exactly and so he's a
guy so I called it Bryan I was like hey
you'll never believe this man [ __ ]
Ames he called up and they want to do a
reality show set at the comic book store
he goes I bet you [ __ ] Flanagan hated
that I said I just asked him he goes
what he says he said no he goes why he
said he said he didn't want to be Snooki
Bryan who doesn't want to be Snooki like
there had just been an article about
like Snooki made 5 million bucks
captured everyone's imagination so he
did it he didn't want to do it but he
wanted to get a knee surgery so I was
like if the show takes off did you make
some loot you can get your knee fixed
yeah I'll [ __ ] do it and so we want
to shoot like the pilot of this thing at
the store and where I come from people
don't aspire to [ __ ] much like nobody
dreams because maybe they do now but
when we were kids like my father be like
see that mountain never [ __ ] climate
you can't do that yeah let other people
tell you about it so you weren't really
encouraged to dream and you're always
terrified that someone's gonna think
you're gonna make you look like an
[ __ ] oh my god it's crazy so much
pride in Jersey as you grow up next to
New York yeah you're the butt of
everybody's [ __ ] joke and so there's
a lot of chip on your shoulder [ __ ] so I
showed up to shoot the sizzle reel with
the boys and they were leaning everyone
else's buzz of electricity [ __ ]
production and there they are leaning
against while like two dudes at a high
school dance like I'm [ __ ] ditch and
[ __ ] like that yeah expression like I
just recognize it and I said let's go
outside real quick and so I went outside
with Brian Walton I was like look man I
don't know how to say this but I got no
more magic tricks left up my sleeve like
I didn't even create this [ __ ] this
felon in my [ __ ] lab yeah you could
have a [ __ ] tea you never imagined
you'd be on TV I get it you don't give a
[ __ ] about that but somebody will
literally pay you to sit on TV and
[ __ ] say the things that you're gonna
say to him for free and you're gonna say
to me for free like don't [ __ ] this up
don't just don't phone it in just like
[ __ ] be you be charming do do the
podcast just do it on camera and they
and to their credit they did it like
rather than sitting there and be like
[ __ ] this they [ __ ] did what
eventually the show became and it got
picked up so we got lucky when I first
saw the first pilot of the show they
didn't really do just Pawn Stars in
comic store it was kind of like clerks
the reality series and I said that I was
like oh my god this is like clerks the
reality series and they're like what do
you think we were making yeah and I was
like Pawn Stars we come up show a story
and they're like that wouldn't last very
long so six seasons we've been on we
just wrapped season nice congratulations
but I mean as everything dude Walking
Dead we follow a juggernaut you know
yeah yeah we don't even have to try for
an audience it's just like the people
that don't turn off the Walking Dead
yeah that's more than enough
do you follow Walking Dead or talking do
it talking and they've got a huge number
too it's true it's well we do follow
sometimes it's walking talking then
they'll play walking again yeah and then
we happen a good night that's tough well
I mean again it's like it's a free show
like I literally don't have to do
anything like there's no writers room
camera show up and then the boys yeah
they turn them on and they just have to
generate the whole [ __ ] show yeah so
I always like I'm happy for them because
they're not dudes that ever ever like
I'm a thinker I'm smart I'm original
like they did there were not
self-express errs and yet there they are
six seasons of a show that like most
sitcoms where the writers room don't get
them any seasons yeah and it's all
predicated on just their ability to talk
to one another like they would every day
anyway
yeah so I love that show cuz they just
get paid to be them [ __ ] selves it's
kind of and I get to watch them you guys
are all like you guys all grew up
together collecting comic books and
whatnot
not so much grew up together doing it
like I met Walter when I was when I got
out of high school as a teen but he he
was a guy that believed in it like he
liked when I went sighs I loved comic
books I was a kid then when I went to
high school is like I'm not [ __ ] to
talk about comic books I'm gonna get
[ __ ] and so didn't work didn't work you
sold out on comic books for [ __ ] again
and [ __ ] didn't pan out for me gonna
make so many nerds may learn that later
on
Walter Flanagan was a [ __ ] person
taught me to be myself I met him working
at this Highlands Recreation Center
there's a latchkey kid program for
after-school kids yeah so he worked in
this place all the time I was there for
one year for this government program and
we worked together eight months and the
dude and I never spoke like he would
speak to me through the kids yeah so kid
would be like are we playing kickball
today like I say the wall we playing
kickball today and he turned to a kid
and be like we playing kickball today
Matt and Bill yeah and they'd go outside
and be like I guess we're playing
[ __ ] kickball we did we communicated
like divorced parents divorcing parents
through the children so after eight
months of like not talking us dude I
said to the boss I was like what how do
you reach [ __ ] Walter Flanagan like
I've been working with eight months this
dude just does not give a [ __ ] about
anything I have to say goes he likes
comic books and isn't really I used to
read comic books was alright so we were
playing foosball the next day with two
kids and that's a long game when you
play foosball two five-year-olds they
can't even see over the [ __ ] table
all they want to do is spend so I had a
long time to talk to him so I was like
hey man I understand you like comic
books it was like yeah and that's what a
bonding began no you just [ __ ] that
was it yeah - keep digging those well I
like comic books when I was kid I just
read comics all the time and then I
stopped when I went to high school
because I wanted to get laid and as the
first time we made eye contact with me
he's across the game from he looks up it
goes but the [ __ ] does that mean
and I was like well I was just like most
people think comics are for kids he's
like what [ __ ] people think that and
I was like not me but others and [ __ ]
like that
he reached into his back pocket he pulls
out a copy of the Dark Knight Returns
tray pack
back which is pretty [ __ ] thick keep
the rolled up in your ass pocket and
he's like read this take this home read
this and you tell me if this is for
[ __ ] kids and went home I read it and
I was [ __ ] amazing one of the
greatest pieces of American literature
ever produced just happens that Batman
in it too
yeah so I went to work the next I was
like this is [ __ ] genius this is
where comic books are now yeah I want
back in he goes yes that is a current
comic book he's going time somebody
tells you that comics are for kids
you shown this image of Batman breaking
a [ __ ] spine that's not for sure
that's metal he talked that would say
you taught me to like like it like like
nothing everybody I saw somewhere that
like you had you had a pretty good
collection right you had to sell it off
for your first movie yeah like that was
because of Walter I got that good
collection because I started hanging out
with them yeah and I started going like
well I'm gonna buy books too and I built
a collection which then later on finance
clerks a couple years later so at the
peak how much do you think your
collection was worth I did a value if
you go by the guide you know it's just
like the Overstreet guide is usually the
over price guide yeah going by the
Overstreet guide my collection was only
ten thousand and change yeah so I was
trying to sell that and I couldn't get
that and I tried to sell it to comic
book stores couldn't get that so I wound
up selling the old collection for $2,000
store credit Jesus I know so I would
sell off the store credit to walter he'd
spend $180 dropping from the town if you
would have held on to those and let them
appreciate how much you think they would
have been well then I wouldn't have made
clerks and I'd be sitting at home
reading the collar not having a
conversation with you guys be here it is
Airbnb huh
my podcast go they sound pretty cool I
wish I'd taken a shot in life but no I
had to hold on to my comedy well they're
worth something now
there's too many TV shows man yeah
sometimes people tell me their favorite
shows three of them I haven't even heard
of it was so much [ __ ] that's progress
that's huge progress do you think about
how many generations back someone in
your family Billy you know what I have a
problem with it would not be anything
close to too much TV I can't watch it
all we're in a good world I know
everyone always likes to talk about how
shits blown up in Korea [ __ ] blah
blah but you know we're in a good world
where it's like there's so many [ __ ]
shows I searched the ball yeah you'll
never be bored again in this half time I
wonder what it was like to be on Leave
It to Beaver that [ __ ] had to be
pandemonium was leaving the Beavers
competition they're like we are one of
three programs on the planet to watch us
you were competing with a talking horse
rascals big would give up five years in
two years and they could have literally
just done episodes where they sat around
smoking looking at each other because
people like what else would - mr. Edie
that was that was a hot show and it was
a talking [ __ ] arse it's probably
work today I bet you think Network oh my
god if Netflix did a mr. edge show
everybody would be like it's genius
well that's I think there's that kind of
a spoof on mr. ed he's like he was like
a little bit but it's also just a spoof
in general it's a Hollywood spliff yeah
it's a great show watch the van oh no of
a washed-up sitcom star this is
melancholy
check me out on season four Anna will do
that we mention something that like he
was a newbie like no I'm blu-ray and DVD
[Music]
if you're not willing to advocate for
your own work
you can't expect others you know it's
like I'll be the first one I wear my
[ __ ] self on my chest there you go
people like that's tacky I'm like I'm a
billboard yeah there's been some stuff
though some projects without that I've
done and then I saw the final you know I
can't help push this I've done my piece
already that's uh I guess that but
that's if you're acting for some if
you're not in charge of the thing yeah
and if even if you even if you er if
you're in charge of the thing even if
you made something that you do like oh I
don't I'm not you don't support it's
right on but yeah how weird is that what
must that feel like to be in something
where you're like okay where people yeah
because something I see it this is not
good and then they hey can we get some
tweets and can you show what Larry's cuz
you'll like turn down pilots he'll be
like I don't want the pressure of being
on the first one people's pilots like
NAT the main not the main row but a
supporting role and somebody's fighting
on it I don't know I don't want you than
that get this deal because we didn't
have all good on camera kit more
Electric today than you know I'm a
smoker you a smoker I read that you did
you stop eating sugar completely I did
although this week I've okay podcast
exclusive I had this cotton candy like
I'm you know sugar is obviously a big
weakness mine I had this cotton candy
that was spun from organic pineapple
sugar okay and they sold it like a
loophole a little bit I felt like this
is natural and it was sweet but it
wasn't it didn't taste like sugar
artificial sweetener right amazing but
yeah I've given up sugar like going back
to when did I it's about
years I saw this documentary fed up and
that was the one that changed they put
it into a cartoon I was like oh is that
what I'm doing Oh so I took sugar out
the equation so they were just basically
it's like Joe Rogan always lies about
that base they just basically telling
you sugars poison I mean ever since I
was a kid they used to say that not to
children they're really triggers boys
and there's put it in everything for you
but it's bad they always say it's bad
for your body yeah and they're
apparently very very right yeah you know
now there was always kind of like heart
disease was pushed on fat's yeah and now
they're finding out that has everything
to do sugar he's good so like what is
candy you're just a big fan of candy
that's what was the love sweetness yeah
yeah oh my god that's my poison like
I've never got a taste for alcohol but
like I could kill a [ __ ] six-pack of
you faster than he could drink a beer
uh-huh that's not much of a brag what is
the so what was the first couple weeks
like of trying to know I was bereft
which is a word I never [ __ ] use them
it's a very happy in [ __ ] but I was
literally bereft like I remember at one
point like I couldn't manufacture happy
thought and I told my wife because I got
concerned I was like not for nothing but
I think I need to go to a therapist or a
psychiatrist she's like what why and I
was like I I can't there are good things
happening in life and I just feel
[ __ ] miserable and I can't
manufacture a positive thought like I
don't know what the [ __ ] going I've
never felt like this before you had
serious withdrawal I don't know what
that's sort of why she goes haven't you
just off sugar I was like what are you
talking about she's like your whole
[ __ ] the food pyramid of your diet is
predicated on [ __ ] sugar and you just
removed it it's a drug at the end of the
day drugs she was saying she's like just
higher J when you went off heroin and
had to detox your detoxing and once I
realized that I was like oh my god they
explained everything and then like a
week later body just regulated and
suddenly I could feel good again yeah I
did the I did the no sugar diet thing
and it and it does help and you did you
notice that like once you got off the
sugar you didn't like after a certain
amount of time you stopped craving it we
all just had like you could see a cake
and be like yeah I don't know that I
could really be around yeah sweet [ __ ]
and just feel like man it's not calling
yeah yeah definitely you get in
nice zone with it yeah what it takes you
know you got to put some distance you
lose serious weight when you take the
sugar out your diet yeah like yeah lost
85 just fell off Wow without even like
you know no gym
it took four months Wow we working out
no I'll walk the dogs once a day up you
lost 85 pounds and four more getting rid
of sugar just killing off of sugar and
walking up a hill walk the dogs once
again that's [ __ ] Christ
oh wait there's sugar no sugars I mean
no berries yeah I took it all out not
even a little [ __ ] no free yeah Wow
yeah come on hole you know some people
like to use now sweeteners and [ __ ] so
what the [ __ ] were you eating the whole
time
at that point I went to prison
everything yeah it is especially if it's
prepared yeah but I was eating a lot of
meats your diet becomes very Atkins II
yeah it's all protein yeah at that point
me were you even eaten great because
grains yeah I cuz grains turn into
starch which - yeah but I was like one
thing at a time
give up the breads as well yeah but I
was a big milk or as well yeah which is
proud the only sugar I would get from
the lactose in milk yeah and I would
drink a [ __ ] ton of milk and then I
directed an episode that's so weird but
I direct an episode the Goldbergs yeah a
couple months back and Jeff Garlin who
I've known for years he's on that show
and we were having this conversation
around the monitor about like you know
he's like there's three things you give
up give them up you lose weight you
never have to exercise
what are they goes sugar I did that he
was gluten I said yeah get my head
around doing that he goes dairy as a
[ __ ] you you can't take the cow yeah and
so I was driving home because I used to
drink gallon a half two gallons of milk
a day I was driving home was pouring
rain and my wife called up but she's
like hey you want to stop get milk
because you shouldn't I was like if I
got home there's no milk I get all
shitty I'm like I'll do all the work
guys were wonderful good thing where's
the bill she's like before that happened
you're on your way home pick up some
[ __ ] milk and so is a guy and so I
had moved from whole milk to this like
triple filtered milk and [ __ ] like that
so
you know it had all 13 yeah yeah but
like a third of the sugar some so as
already it was kind of like methadone
milk like when a heroin addict moves to
methadone and you're like wow there's
something but it ain't the same milk so
I was like you know it's raining out and
[ __ ] and [ __ ] I'm already on the
methadone mill cousin let me see if I
could go a week without drinking milking
so I just didn't stop and pick it up and
I got home my wife's like where's the
milk oh [ __ ] why didn't you stop get
milk and I was like no no no calm down
as I'm just gonna would try to go
without it for a week and she's like
well don't [ __ ] hang out here she's
like it was anything like sugar you'll
be shitty but I wasn't I would but the
first thing she said she's like I start
going like I'm gonna stop drinking milk
she goes why and I was like wow I don't
know maybe it's just I feel like I've
given up sugar I'm not sure I give it up
milk and she goes who are you [ __ ]
nobody she goes why do you where'd you
get this idea exactly
I said Oh Jeff Garlin told me this and
she goes Kevin you're gonna take health
advice from Jeff Garlin I was like I
sound like a good idea so I gave a milk
recently - yeah that did that shed some
pounds as well not not as much as like
you know like if I have to think about
it I probably enjoyed drinking milk more
than dark definitely more than not
drinking milk but the benefits not like
I lost another 20 euros in milk yeah you
know on one level I'm like I could see
myself slipping back in the milk but my
kid is a vegan so she's 17 she could be
18 so she's always like and she used to
see me drinking milk she'd be like not
your mom not your milk guilt and because
I was raised on milk and her generation
wasn't yeah raised on soy sounds like
the human way to take something from
something as natural milk in the story
of humanity when you said your
daughter's
17 - give me 18 next month yeah when
does she show cuz she's in oh yeah
that's right she's in your last movie
where does she show the inclination to
be a performer or up until dusk she had
been a bass player yeah and I figured
that's what she'd wind up doing but we
did this movie too
and I had like there's a scene where I'd
written it for some guy working in a
convenience store and then I was like
you know what man like let me I'm gonna
put my kid in it because let's be honest
she's never gonna get a real job let's
see what that little look and so she was
uh you know Johnny Depp was in the movie
as well and she was gonna be in a scene
with Johnny
and so Harleys one of her closest
friends is Johnny's daughter lily-rose
so she's like Lily Rose is coming to
watch us act tomorrow
is it really why she goes she thinks
it's [ __ ] up like she's known me since
she was a kid she's known her father her
whole life she never imagined we'd
[ __ ] act together and stuff I was
like well she can be there like just how
about we put her in it like you know
instead of you doing all the dialogue
you'll have somebody sit there and talk
to and she's usually I'd be alright
she's gonna but I don't know if her
parents and she fell in love with it
like after that she only worked for the
one day but she was real natural both
her and Lily and that's how that Yoko's
movie happened because they were in this
one scene in tusk as these two
characters and I was like oh my god I
would love to watch a whole movie just
about those two [ __ ] girls that hate
Americans and so I was like [ __ ] it
right there do you guys catch some
nepotism flak for that Oh before the
moment we announced it there was what
was this game franchise Ford Coppola he
knows there was a bunch of like oh this
is not a movie this is a play date and
[ __ ] like that and to be fair though the
same people that wrote that upon the
announcement of the movie stuck to their
guns and wrote that review when they saw
the movie yeah so you know consistency
counts for something I guess or they
just predicted this is how I'm gonna
feel until the end of time some people
just hate the [ __ ] out of my [ __ ] ass
and some of the things I do I yeah
something you got to deal with but um
but that [ __ ] flick I it's I love it
it's a like a puppet master movie I was
a big fan of those movies I was kid
radio
kind of like a puppet man it's my
version of a puppet master movie but she
had a blast doing tasks so I was like
[ __ ] I'll put you in this if you're an
acting I can't help you with [ __ ]
bass guitar I could drive you to a gig
or buy your guitar but like I know
something about acting I know [ __ ] my
make movies yeah so I started putting
her in stuff and now that's what she
wants to do she graduates in two three
weeks and everyone else he's gonna well
I mean I guess she'll go like take
classes and stuff but she's not going to
college like okay she's like I know what
I want to do and I was like oh my god
good for you I skipped college - I did a
little bit I never even got to my
associates degree yeah but like my wife
her mom is you know art program because
she wants to see her go to college and
[ __ ] but she knows what she wants and
plus college don't go away like five
years from now she wants go to college
they'll take her [ __ ] money yeah but
you know why make her go if she's not
feeling it right now oh you have a [ __ ]
what a theremin is what you should have
done instead of paying 250 for that song
you ain't kiddin that sounds like tusks
right there and the amazing thing is now
it sounds like you quote-unquote played
it yeah but he literally just held his
hand there yeah well then now you're
moving that's actually playing the
starting to get up I'm trying to get a
placement the next movie Oh song lyrics
- yeah I don't know is that how
songwriting works well don't they have
to come up with the song first and then
write the lyric and it lyrics at the
same time yeah man this guy's are you
doing comedy because if you can ride the
mood music and the lyrics at the same
time you own the world I'm just using it
I'm using comedy on my music I found
that the path to music the one nobody's
taken is comedy right smart who did that
was that a gift you buy I bought
I bought it as a gift for my niece and
nephew
then I found out they weren't using it I
have my sister send it back and then oh
my god your uncle Indian giver a Native
American and and also I bought you one
at least in New York but you're like no
now goes oh my god yeah every time we
have a gig of pop pop up at the air B&B
and I was like who brought the theremin
here is like oh man we got another one
this is like 300 bucks
yeah to enjoy it gives you yes without
even reaching for it to touch it as he
speaks about it was pride that people
speak about the children this is about
one of my three therapists this has
changed his life legit change his life
one day I kid you not he wakes up
hungover we're at an area Coachella and
it was hungover he just gives out this
old man guy oh he walks over to therapy
then just happy it's silly what is what
do you mean can one master it yeah well
it's just fun you know I'll play it over
it will just play rap songs a different
song and just try to find a good way it
was fun about well this is the thing
well this is the fara mini and there's a
lot of automated features on right it's
not a flat-out traditional thing yeah
like it stays there's a pitch corrector
so there's a pitch closers doing a lot
of work force doing a lot of work for
you
where's when you use like the actual
theremin like every tiny little
millimeter it makes makes a difference
in Oh Mitch yeah all that but this this
one is more like the the cookie cutter
version right so it's great those
[ __ ] take it away from
almost like look I know what it is it's
okay
well what would happen if somebody gave
you an actual theremin do you think I
want to get one you're working your way
up to it yeah we're gonna finally go to
this is made by Moog and we probably
they have a festival yeah what ages have
it's a music festival they have a bunch
of different you know oak Momo cups and
a row
Moke yeah mogh but but they have a fest
I think I'm gonna go to the fest
I really I don't know what I'm gonna do
that go watch some shows and yeah
probably play I probably have he's
moving in and instantly the smile
broadened his face I'm telling you
that's the you're the best commercial
for the [ __ ] theremin that we've been
working on this what I should put you on
a spot just literally you're right no
copy just put you walk into a room this
is sitting on an Apple box
yeah you come in and just put more
mature hand goes in front of it you
light up like Christmas do it touch it
touch it I think that's a great idea Oh
No
[Music]
Chester we mix it we just goof off that
is [ __ ] for lot of fun space yeah man
good wow this is different tone from the
side here you have a conversation go
you'd go from this ah go for massage and
we came um you've enlightened me I'm
gonna try to bring some tech here into
my podcast yeah we usually have a drum
machine too but we just got it back but
yeah usually we drum around it's make
make songs live a lot of times we make
hits on here really mitten hits making
hits man at least in our heads the other
hot 16 you can throw me real quick at 16
come on Hannibal Harry Styles a lot on
there give me a give me uh give me a
total fire throw fire
Charl the Kowski Charles Bukowski yep
Charles Bukowski I don't know much about
him he was a great author he's about 40
would he start think I said hot 16 not a
lot for I've never been on a yacht or a
smaller boat no boats of any size
don't take no cruises I'm not one of
those guys nice that was it stars might
I suggest Bukowski rhymes perfectly with
a bow ski a bow ski yeah yeah and then
you hit a little of this
knowing that music was this simple are
you gone into music
yes sit around with friends I just say
[ __ ] and touch things yes yeah these
days are so automated and that like you
can look like you could get like
consumer-level gear and just literally
sparked a band by yourself like JJ
Abrams man like I remember when I did
that show alias like there was a story
that went around where he composed the
theme song yeah and I was like what like
how do you he created the show he's
making the show he made the music as
well yeah I guess around with music and
[ __ ] and he did he created the score
first and I remember thinking that guy's
talented yeah even though he'd been you
know making [ __ ] for a while but that
that music thing pushed me over the top
I'm like Jesus I mean it still takes
like talent to like figure out notes and
have music theory or whatever like know
stuff but as far as like work flow and
like you know back in the days I
synthesizer a theremin would like you'd
have to like tune it yourself and it'd
be all kinds of crazy technical [ __ ] you
have to learn but nowadays everything is
so automated you can just literally put
your hand up and then these are
synthesized let's throw some drums spit
a hot 16 you got a hit guess some of the
best podcast acid I pull up to meet you
got to be undies add on that do you play
it through there we've done a bunch of
ants we do way more we do way too much
work on our ads really produced we
really producing ads that's him on the
drums and then I played the theremin
over to beat
[Music]
ha ha triggers up sunny be kissing me
undies and we went to smoke up some
trees and I got all hot and I may be
single you know they're dicks at me I'd
be single and I wear some drugs to cover
my balls is beyond a screech beef with
y'all after brunch me and his girl hung
out on a Sunday oh my god if I was me
undies I would be overpaying exactly my
commercial for me undies is like thank
you free [ __ ] Underpants guys
literally put some thought it beat not
like he was a he was at my crib cuz
usually we do the pockets of my place in
Chicago and he was on the phone with
[ __ ] around I was like whatever I'm
just gonna make this beating and wait
for it wait for him to be ready and then
he just came in and he started hitting
the theremin I'm like alright I keep
that in high hats and then the [ __ ] came
together like 15 minutes maybe tops so
wait it's like you know gala fun yeah
yeah yeah
do they use is that where they get one
it was a sin it was a it was a moke
synthesizer but it wasn't it wasn't a
theremin but it was it's basically the
same the same sound but a different
approach it was just I think it was a
Voyager when did somebody say hey let's
put let's theorem let's put a theremin
version of this like a theremin no that
I think the theremin is the OG I think
the theremin came out before the
synthesizer this version or you don't
know your meninges the theremin total
but who decided to make it for me or you
or Hong use this is Momo just mo mo has
this Thurmond and then they have a they
have like the real theremin too so they
made this one more for like children and
like people that want to [ __ ] with the
theremin but don't really quite because
it takes a lot of practice in a lot it
takes a lot of work to be good at it
theremin right you know you know I'm
saying to be able to do the same thing
multiple exactly yeah it's a very big
reason for it but the idea
we're gonna play this song for the 16th
time yeah this week and it has to be on
I know there's some bands that were
using theremins back in the days and
running them through like a pitch
corrector pedal just so it could make it
easier you know but basically they took
that idea of a pitch corrector and just
put it inside the theremin that way
you're never off key and then you could
set your route your scale everything so
if you want to go like F sharp and keep
everything at F sharp scale BAM the
whole thing yeah and kids didn't want
this I didn't want I think they just
appreciate just get inside other stuff
what do you think the parents were like
no don't pick it up it's making more
noise so this was a cool gift it wasn't
just like I was walking through an
airport here's a theremin no we were
like you like music right it was that
but is I think it's just they get a lot
of stuff and you know it kind of fell to
the wayside if I bought it for them in a
the middle of March instead of Christmas
right they might appreciate it more but
it came at Christmas when everybody's
trying to give them [ __ ] kind of how I
say now that you know that the lesson
you get from this yeah just give them
things you want yeah because you know
you're gonna get it back I'm gonna start
giving people gifts just randomly
Christmas man yeah everybody right with
everybody and I don't want to wear
costume on Halloween yeah I'm gonna
dress up like Pikachu in August files
play when you want yeah never mind this
mandatory [ __ ] yeah who makes the rules
you make the rules just that yeah
Pikachu is a oddball but I'm all our
support I don't know why I thought
Pikachu I was your first grab yes you're
still in right mode I'm just trying to
find a ride before Pikachu and if you
could slam it into a me undies jam holy
[ __ ] Pikachu Pikachu wait wait to you
here the hot jammer will make for you on
this on this episode we don't get me and
a Pikachu yeah man you know we're gonna
make you
original track for what your next
project
yeah you could use it or not done sorry
kidding me I'll put it in just for the
conversation that people like let's say
200 people watch it in the theater yeah
three people are gonna be like can you
believe he used that [ __ ] track no
we're going to do it we would take this
challenge there's gonna be some theremin
and some wrapping done do you know how
much background music has to go into a
movie yeah like you need I got you man I
got to [ __ ] free and I don't spend on
the quarter you sleep with prices yeah
because I fleetwood maxed out than that
thank you for coming through man thanks
for having so this is a lot of fun it
was way convenient to here for me three
miles away but still [ __ ] better than
like being in a hotel room second was
smart cast swag guest comics mike has
died communist has all the podcast stuff
everything's thanks a lot Kevin Smith
but haven't met good talking yeah yeah
thanks for coming down Thanks
[Music]
[Music]